[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm John Connelly The Spectators news
editor this week we're going to be
talking about a pretty horrific attack
which occurred in Clapham last week it's
a chemical attack against a woman and
two of her daughters the lead suspect is
still on the run but the case has pretty
disturbing implications when it comes to
National policy talk to me about this is
the academic professor of politics and
international relations Matt Goodwin
he's also the author of several books
and his own
substack Matt to to start us off can you
explain to us a bit about the lead
suspect in this case um chap called
Abdul aedi um especially in terms of how
did how did he come to this country how
did he arrive him and why is he still
here yeah well I think in many ways this
case symbolizes much that wrong with the
country this is somebody who entered
Britain
illegally uh we are told on a lry in
2016 who then applied for Asylum twice
was denied then went on to commit uh
what we're told a serious sexual
offenses and was indeed convicted um uh
in
2018 then applied for Asylum again and
this time around his application was
approved um because he claimed to have
converted to
Christianity uh and a priest uh signed
off on that uh that claim um and of
course then he went on to commit these
absolutely horrific acts um of violence
and attempted murder uh against um the
mother and her two young children so
look to me this isn't actually about an
individual case what this is is a symbol
of how our Asylum system is simply
no longer fit for purpose that's
essentially what this case is
about Matt there's tons to unpack there
and like you say it seems to sort of
point the finger at several parts of the
British state of being being a
tremendous issue um let's start with the
fact that a EDI had been convicted of a
sexual offense and then received ayum I
think most people watching this would be
quite surprised that anyone who's
convicted of that sort of crime will be
allowed to stay in the UK I mean what
what's going on there how has that been
allowed
well the first thing to say is he's
certainly not alone we have somewhere in
the region firstly around 10,000 foreign
National offenders in Britain's uh jails
um we've seen um think tanks recently um
like the center for policy studies point
to the number of foreign Nationals who
are on Britain streets having coni
convicted sorry having committed very
serious crimes or actually planning acts
of terrorism some of them them uh have
even been pointed to by MI5 and the
security services as a serious ongoing
threat to the Safety and Security of the
British people um this is not by the way
what most ordinary Brits want I pulled
them on this 75% say they do not think
foreign Nationals who commit crime
should be allowed to stay in the country
and they also feel the same way about
foreign Nationals who glorify terrorism
they should be removed from the country
and we just had recent survey in France
finding the same over 80% of the French
say if you commit a crime uh you enter
the country you're from you're not from
the country you commit a crime you
should be removed um what's going on is
that we have um a human rights
architecture a legal
architecture um that is partly supported
by UK legislation things like the Human
Rights Act modern slavery acts and so on
which allows these individuals to
essentially gain the system uh even if
they've entered the country illegally
even even if they've be um committed
serious uh crimes um and in some cases
as in this case um it's not just that
they're able to uh successfully obtain
um uh Asylum but they they then go on to
to commit even more serious uh crime so
uh we are I think in a very vulnerable
position we know the numbers of illegal
migrants are going up we know we've had
about 12,000 people enter the country
illegally since 2018 we know we have no
serious ongoing solution to the Border
crisis and alongside that we know that
overall levels of migration are also
surging to Historic high so many people
will be watching this case firstly
saying I think we should do whatever we
need to do in terms of judicial
arrangements to ensure that we
prioritize the Safety and Security of
the British people to me that's a
no-brainer what we have is a system that
does the opposite it actually
prioritizes the interests and the wishes
uh and the priorities of illegal
migrants over the Safety and Security of
British people and I personally think
that needs to
change Matt we should we should mention
here that the rules were toughened last
year by swella braveman when she was
Home Secretary I think it used to be
that if you convicted of if you
sentenced to over four years in prison
your as salum decision would not be
usually be approved that was lowered to
12 months do you think that's low enough
or do you think it should be applied
wider I actually take quite a hard line
on this my view is if you're a foreign
National particularly like as ad and
you've entered the country illegally I
think firstly illegal migrants unless
they um unless they have a genuine uh
reason uh for being here should be
removed from the country full stop and I
think Those who commit crimes especially
should be removed uh irrespective of
appeals to uh human rights uh
conventions um I you know what we've
seen in recent years has been truly
scandalous I wrote about it on on
substack if you look at the cases for
for example of of murderers uh rapists
Class A drug dealers who have been taken
off deportation flights because of
judicial activism by by lawyers and by
NOS um it is absolutely outrageous when
you look at some of the cases that that
that have slipped through uh that net
and I think more generally to be frank
what it's pointing to is the power and
influence of what some have called the
charity industrial complex that
surrounds the judicial system that we
have an army of of NOS think tankers
lawyers and so forth who will basically
do whatever they can to prevent anybody
and everybody from being deported from
the country and this is a minority view
right this is a minority view as I say
over 70 80% of Voters do not want these
things to be happening and also if you
ask the Brits do you think we should
leave International courts and
conventions that would allow us to have
much more control over who comes in and
out of the country they say absolutely
uh they are open to leaving things like
the European convention on human rights
by the way which zel bravman and others
have called for it is not true that that
is a very unpopular policy if you frame
that policy as giving us much greater
control over dealing with people like
Abdul aidi most Brits fall in line and
say absolutely I think you know we we're
now at a point with a global migration
crisis with serious threats from radical
islamism and from radical islamist
violence and by the way we've just seen
that with Mike frier the Member of
Parliament being forced out of office by
radical islamists um I think many people
now are realizing that actually what we
need to do is overhaul and strengthen
our existing legislative uh architecture
so we can deal with these cases much
more
robustly um turning to another aspect of
the aedi case Matt I mean one you
mentioned there in your your first
answer um the fact that aedi seemingly
was able to gain a salum at least
partially because he converted to
Christianity um it seems It's come
forward that there's evidence that that
that that conversion is apparently bogus
or appears very much appears to be bogus
um how how much of a problem do you
think this is it's a very more widely
it's not just I think other people have
made this point just just as eloquently
I've seen Melanie Phillips being one of
them who's written about it the Church
of England have some serious questions
to answer we know that we've got I think
looking at the latest numbers 40 or 50
of the illegal migrants on the boat who
have applied for uh Christian uh applied
applied but have started the conver
process I should say um essentially
using this as a way to gain the system
that's what's happening here this is not
a sudden you know um uh uh conversion to
to Christianity this is a crude uh means
of gaining the system and I I think when
we talk about the influence of of the
charity industrial complex that also
includes Many religious institutions who
often led by people who have good
intentions but who are I think actually
um making the situation a lot worse uh
whoever signed off whoever signed off on
a zidi um I'd like to know who they are
I think we should be having a debate
about what happened in that process how
was that process managed um I think it's
utterly ridiculous that that kind of
criteria is used to allow somebody who's
already um committed serious sexual
offenses to stay in the country I don't
think that's correct I don't think the
British people should have somebody like
that walking around the streets uh of
their country and if you look at the you
know the the ACT consequences are are
serious if you look for example at say
the Liverpool bomber same Story asylum
Seeker came into the country claimed to
be a Christian and then gain the system
went on to try and bomb uh the hospital
in Liverpool we're not talking about
things here that don't matter we're
talking about things that have serious
consequences for the British people and
what I would argue is we're seeing the
ongoing influence of of of the luxury
belief class in this country people who
pursue and Advocate policies
like open borders like relaxed policies
on refugees and illegal migrants who
will not suffer the cost of those
policies but which will impose enormous
cost on other people like the mother and
the two daughters who who suffered this
horrific attack um that's what we have
in this country an Elite Class within
the institutions within the Church of
England I would argue within the NOS or
Charities the courts who are routinely
advocating luxury beliefs that bring
them very few if any costs but it but
seriously um impact in a negative way
the ways of life for ordinary British
people for ordinary families trying to
go about their job that is ultimately at
the heart of this this isn't really
about Abdul aidi I mean he's a nasty
piece of work I hope he's found I hope
he's removed from the country this is
actually about the new Elite who are
running the institutions in this country
who have a fundamentally different view
of these issues than the vast majority
of British people who have to live with
the consequences of them we should on on
that vein mention some of the responses
from government figures I mean in
particular we had education secretary
Jillian Keegan say that this case is not
really about Asylum it's about violence
against women I mean what did you make
of that well I thought it was a great
example of just how weak our political
class have become Jullian Keegan uh
strikes me as somebody who probably
should be in the liberal Democrats
rather than the conservative party if
you look at actually what this case is
about clearly is about a broken illegal
migration system that has been exploited
by this individual who has clearly been
briefed and informed how to play the the
how to um uh exploit the rules how to
cut the corners how to get a third
Asylum application through the system
despite having convicted a serious
sexual assault and exposed himself to
somebody sorry this is about Asylum this
is about illegal migration this is about
the borders being in chaos this is about
the government for the last 14 years
still not finding a way of actually
strengthening the borders and not
finding a way of prioritizing the
security of the British people and the
other thing is by the way while we're
having this conversation is this is also
about what we don't know one of the
things we don't know in this country is
just how much serious crime and violence
is committed by illegal migrants and
Asylum Seekers largely because it's very
difficult to get hold of the data we
don't really know uh just how uh endemic
some of these issues uh really are I'll
tell you one statistic that we do know
however which the one of our newspapers
confirmed over the last week which is
that Britain now has
the highest rate of chemical attacks
against women in the world we've had
over 700 chemical-based attacks against
women over the last year which is a
sharp increase from the year before now
I had to look at these statistic twice
in one of our national newspapers to
make sure I was reading it correctly
what's that about so I do feel quite
strongly about
it brilliant thank you very much Matt
well thank you for having
me
[Music]